And everybody, welcome to another episode of the Read Your Jeans podcast genetics for everyone.
You have a number of questions that were submitted. So let's just jump right into this and see what we got.
Okay, the first question, why would you tell me to limit gluten if I don't notice any issues?
So I think the person is asking, I don't notice any issues when I eat gluten.
Why would you tell me off the genetic review to limit gluten? Okay, good question.
So understand there's a difference between a gluten sensitivity and a genetic predisposition to a gluten sensitivity and or a full gluten celiac disease.
You know, autoimmune issue with gluten. So with the HLA genes and the KIA genes, if you have defects in that, meaning more than just a single allele defect, especially if you have double allele defects in that, I may say you'd be better for you to be on a gluten free diet.
Now understand you could have no defects in your HLA genes or your KIA genes.
And and you still have a gluten sensitivity because of of issues with your gut damaged gut causing your body to make antibodies to glianid or the glianid peptides.
And now you have antibodies created in glianid peptides and every time you include your causing inflammation and you still could have no.
No obvious symptoms like I don't have a gut pain when I eat gluten, so I must be okay, but it could be causing inflammation the rest of your body can be causing inflammation to your thyroid, it could be causing inflammation to your brain.
So I am only when when you were looking at your genetics, I'm only looking at your genetics for gluten, if you really want to do a go full food sensitivity panel, you have to do a Syrex array two array three array four and array 10 to really get a full picture of your antibody production due to
epigenomic factors meaning lifestyle factors.
Now the HLA genes and the KIA genes just tell you that you have a predisposition to gluten issues, it doesn't mean you do.
So the reason why I tell you on a genetic review to stay off of gluten is because of defects in those genes.
Now understand doesn't mean you have good issues if you have a predisposition to it the only way to know you have is to do a Syrex food panel.
Hopefully that explains it if you if you don't understand about autoimmune issues antibody issues really you should join our autoimmune or chronic health and autoimmune course.
That is my latest course and it's really, really good.
And it will really explain to you about antibodies and autoimmune issues and what you need to do about that to get a handle on.
Next question, can you explain the B C M O genes.
So the B C M O one gene is what we look at on your genetic pathway and that really ties to vitamin A conversion of beta carotene to vitamin A that's usable in your body.
So how you use a vitamin A if you have defects on this family of genes, you got to consider adding, you know, a supplemental vitamin A to your protocol.
So and I always recommend not always, but I usually recommend that you take all your fat soluble vitamins together your A your E your D your K all together so that it's just a better synergy, synergistic atmosphere for your body to absorb these to utilize them they work together synergistically.
And often we see it's not always, but often we see people with B C M O defects also have defects on their media are there vitamin D receptor genes so that's not uncommon to go together.
So it's really utilization B C M O genes utilization of vitamin A how your body can break it down to utilize it in your body if you have defects on it, you should consider supplementing with vitamin A.
I have fatigue issues is this genetic one can be there can be genetic pieces to it.
But usually when you look at somebody comes to me and they have major fatigue issues we want to find out why is genetic.
Is it is genetic the genetic piece the reason why a person has me T T usually not it can be connected so you have defects in your detoxification pathways you are going to be a sluggish detoxer so that can lead to fatigue if you have defects in your histamine pathways you're going to produce a lot more histamine that's a lot more inflammation you're going to have more systemic inflammation.
That could lead to fatigue, but there isn't a fatigue gene or there's no genes that we're looking at that are directly correlated with your toitary gland with your thyroid gland or with your adrenal gland so when you look at fatigue those are the things that you're looking at.
If you've ruled out more serious things like anemia you better do complete blood count test at the blood test a CBC a complete metabolic panel to rule out anemia rule out liver issues rule out some more serious things that you're dealing with then you want to look at looking at an adrenal profile to see your cortisol profile do a full hormone panel.
Test for a pituitary test for thyroid you should be definitely doing a full thyroid panel if you need to know what kind of panels those are look at our autoimmune course because that's when we go into Hashimoto's disease full module autoimmune course is Hashimoto's thyroiditis so we go into the details of that what a full complete thyroid panel is a lot of times people go I had my thyroid test and it was normal.
If you look at their blood test and the doctor ran a TSH thyroid stimulating hormone that's a horrible produced by your pituitary gland it stimulates your thyroid that is that is that is criminal sorry it's just literally criminal that is not thyroid panel thyroid panel then people will go I have full thyroid panel and you look at it as a TSH T3 and T4 you need TSH T3 T4 3 T3 3 T4
reverse T3 thyroid globulin antibodies and TPO antibodies to be even in the category of a full thyroid panel and you need to do a complete blood code CBC in a complete medical panel to row do dont you really need to get a full picture of where you're at.
That's what kind of how do you look at with with fatigue and if you have an underlining condition, you want to look at if there's a person has cancer and they have an increase in fatigue, you're concerned about anemia of product disease where the cancer might be goblet up your iron.
Certainly your iron and your heat pathways can lead to fatigue, but you'll see that on a CVC, you'll see if you have low red lung cold. So you're really looking for anemia with fatigue, you're looking for adrenal issues, thyroid issues with fatigue, pituitary issues with fatigue, other hormonal imbalances with fatigue.
And yes, there's genetic pieces to that, but certainly genetic defect is not going to be the cause of fatigue. You know, directly it's tied together, but not just a specific cause by itself.
All right, thank you for joining us and thank you for listening and never to submit your questions on the reader genes course.
Bye bye.